david and i cooked up this idea for 15
in response to the obama administration
calling for raising the minimum wage to
nine dollars an hour
from 7.25 and we were like if these are
our friends
who needs enemies right like you know
like
if this is the best the president of the
united states can do
we need a new plan the number 15
it sounds like a lot to people but if
productivity if
the minimum wage had tracked
productivity gains oh yeah
22 or something like that and that's
crazy if you look at those curves
that's right and so we knew that 15 was
a relatively conservative number on a
historical basis
it's actually halfway between the
inflation number and the productivity
number
but it seems like a very significant
leap forward because oh yeah
yeah but by rights it should be 25
nationally today
yeah and to be clear andrew if it was
we would live in a very different
country very different wouldn't we
country um
both economically and politically
because a lot of the economic division
that we're
experiencing is a consequence of the
anger
that has been created by the
just objective truth of most people
getting screwed over the last 40 years
right and some people lean left and some
people lean right but the
anger is totally valid and
we have to deal with it
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host
zach grauman on our episode today we've
got nick hanauer
he joins he's an entrepreneur he's a
venture capitalist and he is an activist
who does a lot of work on the minimum
wage super timely
because we just passed this coveted
relief bill and the minimum wage was not
bumped to 15
an hour so it's an interesting timely
conversation with nick but before we do
that guys
i want to pause for those of you i
believe most of you
should know but if not um a man in
georgia in atlanta georgia
went on a killing spree and killed eight
people six of them were asian-american
women
and at this time recording march 20th
the atlanta police department has
not confirmed this to be a hate crime
even though
very very much clearly was and to make
it worse the
the police officer that made a statement
was quoting the man who shot them he
said um
that man had a really bad day it was a
direct quote and um
obviously uh people with bad days don't
do things like this i have bad days all
the time
and this has gotten really bad violence
against the a
api community has spiked since pandemic
started so the
stop aapi hate organization has recorded
3795 hate incidents
since the pandemic started in march
2020. look
i'm a white male i have not experienced
racism
personally anywhere close to any of my
friends of color have
so my perspective is my perspective but
i will say
on this campaign and working with andrew
um
i spent a lot of time getting you know
the aapi community all over the country
a lot of time in fact when we were
running for president
the only people that would really give
us the time of day were the folks in the
asian american community
so some of my best friends and
colleagues and mentors
are asian and part of this community
i've gotten know them very well and they
are hurting this week
andrew and evelyn are hurting this week
i could hear it in their voices i see
her in their faces all week
and it crushes my heart um so i wanted
to pause and
and put pour my love and heart out to my
asian american friends
um i hope you all can do the same but i
also know talk is cheap
so i want to do something i'm i'm going
to donate myself personally there's an
organization i want you guys to know
about
it's called the it's called asian
americans advancing justice they're an
activist group they do a lot of group
work on the ground um so who responds to
incidents like this who
is reaching out to the families but who
also is educating members of the
community how to prevent this and this
one's based they've got an atlanta
chapter so asian americans advancing
justice i'll put the link in the
kind of description of this episode but
i'm going to donate so if you can donate
to either that organization or others
you find that you think are doing great
work please do and and if you can't
i know it's a hard time for everybody
this is what andrew recommended and i
agree the best thing we can do is
start to share our humanity more
proactively so find the best thing you
do is find somebody who doesn't look
like you sign somebody
with a different skin color than you
doesn't look anything like you
and give a smile we must have a mindset
abundance
and fix this deeply inhuman economy and
society we have
it's important to have these moments on
tragedy strike so you feel that and
share our humanity
now with that let's get a little more
positive we're going to talk about some
fun stuff on the podcast with andrew
nick hanauer joins he's a venture
capitalist an entrepreneur he's a really
really impressive individual but he's
done a lot
of good particularly on fighting for the
minimum wage and just talking about it
better um
which is timely it's topical you're
gonna enjoy this one
i love you all enjoy the episode folks
[Music]
[Applause]
when i was in college i used to take
this super food
green smoothie i used to buy one every
day and they were great
and then i moved to manhattan can't
afford them it's like 50 times the price
so how i've substituted that out is with
athletic greens and i've been talking
about them for a while and they're
awesome it's just powder you put it in
water put it wherever you want and you
get
with one scoop minerals and whole food
source ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood
blend and more and they all essentially
work together
to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet increase your energy and focus and
aid with digestion and support a healthy
immune system
which is important during covet and you
don't have to take lots of other
supplements so
right now athletic greens is doubling
down on supporting your immune system
and they're offering our audience a free
one-year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase so if you visit
our link today you'll basically never
have to buy vitamin d
again so visit athleticgreens.com yang
and join health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world who make a daily commitment to
health
every single day again
athleticgreens.com
yang get your free supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
it is my pleasure and thrill to welcome
to the podcast someone i've been wanting
to get on here for a while
serial entrepreneur civic activist
founder of civic ventures pitchfork
economics
rabble rouser extraordinaire nick
hanauer
nick welcome thank you andrew it's so
great to catch up with you
seriously so nick i became a fan of
yours when you wrote that piece in
politico that i guess ended up
kicking off the term pitchfork economics
where you were like hey
fyi the pitchforks are coming for us yes
and they came
and i was like holy crap somebody said
it
like and and it had to be someone like
you
who had had incredible business success
and founded and invested in name brand
companies
and so at one point you were like i
remember that article so well you were
like look guys
i'm in the top one percent and there are
only so many pants i can buy
no for sure and andrew you know i had
when i wrote that article i'd had
a sort of a long-term interest in the
issue of inequality that was spurred by
this incredibly wonky thing that i know
you'll appreciate because you're a
little bit of a wonk yourself
um so i got a look at the income shares
uh that had um that the irs captures
that had gone back a long
time and what i discovered
i got i could look at those in 2006 or
seven
around then and what you discovered when
you look at those
income share numbers was that in 1980
the top 1 of americans shared about
8 percent of national income and the
bottom
50 percent of americans shared about 18
that was in 1980 in 2007
uh the the share of income for the top
one percent had risen to something like
22 or 23 while the share of income for
the bottom 50 percent of americans had
fallen from 18
to 12 and i simply took those numbers
and stuck them in a spreadsheet and said
what happens if this ca
if this happens for another 30 years and
the answer was
armageddon you know like the problem is
is that
if the income for the top 1 percent goes
from 23 to 45
and the income for the bottom 50 percent
goes from 12 to
6 or 5 which is where i think the
numbers took you
it's really super clear that you're not
living in a capitalist democracy anymore
you're living in some sort of
feudal police state yeah
and i was just like holy you know
like
if this doesn't change we're in deep
deep deep trouble and of course
from 2007 on things didn't get better
they got worse
oh yeah dramatically worse and one thing
that was so powerful about that article
which in my mind was like this opening
salvo because you've done all of this
incredible work since then
yeah making the same case but you were
one of the first people to just come out
and debunk the entire
uh hey the top slice of um
taxpayers are like enormous job creators
yeah and so and so you know at the same
time
um sort of like you i got
this terrible urge to understand
where economics had gone wrong because
up to that point the economic profession
had been saying
that all of the policies that had led to
this
enormous amount of concentration of
wealth at the top
we're good for everybody yep right like
that rising tide
lifting that's right like you know
raising wages kills jobs therefore we
shouldn't raise the minimum wage rich
people are job creators the more money
we have
the more jobs we create people are paid
their marginal product which is to say
if you make seven dollars and 25 cents
an hour that's because you're only worth
you know there's this always uh there's
always a trade-off in economic
efficiency um
if you increase justice or fairness in
human societies you know sort of the
canon of neoliberalism and my insti
intuition was that this was all nonsense
right because when you look at
neoliberalism for what it is
it effectively amounts to a
protection racket for the very rich if
you take neo-classical economics and
neoliberalism seriously there's only one
thing that can happen is that the rich
will get richer and everybody else will
get poorer
and so like you i began a journey to try
to
essentially figure out where we went
wrong and to try to get
try to do things that could get us back
on track yeah so
the big theme for this conversation and
you are the perfect person to have it
with
is what the do we do yeah
yeah because here you are you're like a
business titan
um you know you have a platform you make
a very clear rational case which is
correct
uh you point out some of the
uh flawed ideological
um like defense mechanisms that people
have around like the current the current
winner take all economy and its
extremity
um so so you come out and you you say
these things
that you know just about everything out
of your mouth i've always agreed with
um you fight for higher minimum wage in
your own city that ends up helping to
kick off a movement around the country
but i think you would agree with me
particularly during this pandemic
that the extremity is accelerating and
getting worse and
not not somehow getting any better um
and so you know
and you and i connected on this early on
when i decided to run for president i
was like okay here's my approach
here's my plan like let's like um you
know
let's start giving everyone a certain
amount of money to meet their basic
needs
and we had some degree of success but
i'm really interested in what the heck
you found while you've been pushing
these causes uh through civic ventures
and other measures
like how the heck can we turn things
around
to be clear the answer to do what of
what to do to turn things around is very
very simple
uh getting it done politically is very
very hard
but it does so so the answer and you
know
my humble opinion the answer is
is is simply to require
companies to pay uh
their workers enough to live in security
and dignity
and for rich people to pay enough tax
to sustain the investments that make a
democracy
go this is not it is not complicated and
and
the the thing that i want to emphasize
is that if you take neoclassical
economics
seriously then all then you also believe
that
all of the policies that you would you
would impose to do these things
are these efficiency killing job killers
right and that i mean you know if
there's a theme to
what i want to say today on this podcast
is
that is a lie that
that all of that is utter nonsense
that the neoclassical economic models
are rooted in assumptions about human
behavior and the dynamics of human
social systems that are just
objectively false nick i'm just going to
entertain you for a minute
um i studied economics in college and
this is what i remember hang on hang out
i'll show you yeah
yeah exactly supply and demand yeah
wages go up employment must come down
and that
and and and this is just utter nonsense
that
that that believing that so
if you accept the idea that the economy
is this
equal lip closed equilibrium pareto
optimal system
then anything you do to it actually
decreases welfare for everybody but the
problem is the economy isn't that kind
of the invisible hand is not somehow
like you know
omniscient and omnipotent and making it
all happen
no and if there is an invisible hand it
has to do with cooperation not
competition but the truth is that
claiming that when jobs when wages rise
jobs have to fall would be would be
equivalent of claiming that when plants
grow
animals shrink this is obviously
nonsense it's not the way it works
in fact when animal when plants grow so
do animals
yeah and then plants right for food
because it's an ecology
and and there is an ecological
relationship between wages
and business growth and hiring when
workers have more money businesses have
more customers and
hire more workers you've had empirical
experience with this obviously in that
you kicked off the 15
an hour minimum wage in seattle and then
got data
so can you tell us about how that
movement has gone and grown
and i know it seemed like we were this
close uh
to um widespread adoption depending on
you know you were closer to it than i am
in terms of what that
um what what that voting looked like um
in the senate it seemed
yeah so but i i just i just want to
emphasize
that we've been raising the minimum wage
in the united states of america
since 1938.
we you know we've done it federally 22
times
and in zero of those cases
did jobs go down unless the country was
in recession
we've also raised the minimum wage
hundreds of times
in cities and states over the last 80 or
90 years and in zero of those cases
did wages go down the the the thing
that's
remarkable is that because of this
economic theory because of this academic
economic theory that
sees the economy in this sort of
zero-sum relationship
it was not until 1994
that economists even bothered to check
to see if jobs went down after wages
there's a lot of very strange group
thing
you know it's just astonishing and then
this marvelous guy named alan krueger
and his
friend david carr did a study comparing
new york to new jersey where
new jersey raised the weight raised
wages in new york didn't
and discover and their intent in doing
this empirical analysis
was to characterize how much raising the
minimum wage killed jobs
and they discovered to their horror
that not only didn't jobs go down they
may have gone up
and this kicked off a giant kerfuffle in
the academic
economics profession where a nobel
prize-winning economist
um named james buchanan in the wall
street journal
referred to cargan krueger as a bevy of
camp following wow for
for having the temerity to challenge
what he called the bedrock principle of
economics that if wages rise
employment must fall if you can get the
world to believe
that when you raise wages for workers
employment falls
and you are to quote unquote harming the
very people you're intending to help
then you are given both practical and
moral permission
to keep wages low and profits high you
you realize that there truly are these
ideological
bulwarks or defense mechanisms
absolutely people
um and i ran into versions of it over
and over again all over the country
if i had a choice between something like
universal basic income and
a higher minimum wage i would choose
universal basic income
but if like i don't get universal basic
income and the choices raise the minimum
wage then i'm all for raising the
minimum wage
[Laughter]
and i'm on exactly the the other side of
that trade
mostly because i'm a serial entrepreneur
and capitalist right so i really do
believe in capitalism i do believe that
it is a
great economic system the best ever
devised
but i also simultaneously believe
that it is ridiculous and
you know unforgivable to believe that
and also believe that the whole system
will come tumbling down if companies are
required to pay their workers enough
to live in dignity without food stamps
right like it's
nuts there is zero
there is nothing that prevents every
company in america
particularly every big company from
paying their workers enough to get by
without food stamps
i mean heck some of these companies are
then just turning to
uh public subsidies and food stamps
being like hey we're exploiting workers
but don't worry you can like here's a
you know a phone number for food stamps
i mean it's really dark it's very
that's right it's terribly dark and we
don't really have
capitalism true capitalism in this
country we effectively have socialism
for the rich
that you know like most people who get
government assistance
aren't unemployed they
they're employed they have jobs
their employers just don't pay them
enough money
and why don't they pay them enough money
because we collectively have left them
off the hook
because we have been persuaded by this
neoliberal nonsense
that if walmart was forced to pay their
workers enough to get by without food
stamps somehow the whole system will
come tumbling down
meanwhile walmart
to use but one example spends
approximately as much about 6 billion
a year just on stock buybacks as their
employees receive
in public assistance wow it's just crazy
it's nuts and so the thing about
ubi i have no problem with ubi i just
think that the
and you know i can't defend this it just
pisses me off i just think that the
you know the the the easier and quicker
path to get america back on track
is are a set of labor standards that
require
companies to pay people enough to get by
and if we did that
almost all this problem would go away
that's my view i think one of the
reasons why i i'm on the other side of
that was that like i looked at
the political possibility of
changing the labor standards along the
way you suggest in reforming what i see
as like
you know like as you suggest like a very
very deranged version of capitalism
[Laughter]
and i thought like which of these two
two things do i think like you know we
could
make happen and you've been working on
one for quite some time and it's one
reason why you know i want to hear from
you
um like how we move that forward and
then i i jumped in with this other like
version
uh like in part because but i i'm with
you in the sense that
um that that the that we are living in a
world where
uh very large corporations and certain
types of individuals
like are um uh being treated like
incredibly
like you know favorably and generously
but by our system and then we're looking
around saying like oh rugged
individualism for
folks who are working at walmart and the
rest of it that's right this is crazy
you know here here's another canonical
example that people
are using right now is that they the
bailout of the airline industry
uh in the pandemic right well
we so the public taxpayers effectively
gave the airline industry 50 billion
dollars to
help tide them through this difficult
circumstance
but in the prior five years the the
airline industry
spent collectively about 65 billion
dollars
on their own stock returning money to
shareholders into themselves
yeah right so in a way we're just like
pumping all this money essentially
subsidized these selfish
short-sighted bags um
you know because well we've got to save
the industry and protect the workers
so you know you could have protected the
workers you know by
sending the workers money
exactly exactly and you know what scott
galloway
points out frequently you know we should
be kind to people
and merciless to companies part of the
problem here nick is that
like we find it much easier to find the
companies and shove money into their
hands than we do like find the people
but all of that is a consequence of 45
years of neoliberal policy
of getting effectively economics upside
down by
by for by mistaking who the true job
creators in a market economy are
it's it's middle and working class
people
who earn enough to get by
and thrive and consume but also
have the economic security to improve
their circumstances to get good
educations to
effectively raise kids you know like
it's
you know like when i consider how hard
it was for me and my wife
to raise functioning kids given our
circumstances that's actually what got
me to run for president nick
when my wife and i had our first son and
it just beat the out of us so bad
and i was just like
there are two of us we're like
confident we have resources and this kid
is kicking our ass
and i was like how the heck does a
single mom like do do this and then that
that's
actually what made me run for president
the only reason
it requires super hero dumb
to do that is because we have let these
giant corporations
off the hook because if those companies
were required to pay those folks enough
to live in security with one job it
would be possible
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by parachute and i cannot
shut up about parachute like wouldn't
shut up about it so much that my
sister-in-law
just got she's moving into your house
and she just bought a bunch of things on
parachutes website um
and they're awesome i have their sheets
i have their towels i don't know how to
explain it's like
lying it's like sleeping on a freaking
cloud
it's so fluffy and lovely i get out of
shower i wrap myself in like the
bathrobe situation
yeah it's amazing guys seriously
parachute is unbelievable they believe
in making
home your happy place and trust me when
i say this
it actually does make it a bit of a
happy place it is worth every penny so
visit parachutehome.com
yang for free shipping and returns on
parachutes very comfortable premium
quality
home essentials you will not regret it
it's amazing the quality cannot be beat
you'll feel
i don't know you'll just feel like
you're wrapped in joy all the time it's
pretty awesome parachute home
dot com slash yang
so you're talking about this economic
orthodoxy and neoliberalism that i agree
there has been some kind of very strange
almost cultish
acceptance of certain ideas um and you
yourself got a philosophy degree i want
to say out of college and you did not
get an mba or any of that jazz is that
correct
yes correct yeah and then you had but i
did read all the books
just about no no no don't worry about it
like yeah but i'm just
but i'm just suggesting this in part
because i feel like you weren't
acculturated in a particular way it's
like
like a lot of the folks that end up just
imbibing
this stuff like studied maybe economics
in college maybe they got an mba at
harvard maybe they went out there
you know there's a lot of that whereas
you were studying uh
like kant and uh you know that's right
no
and i think you're you're really right
you know if you go to harvard business
school
or stanford business school they teach
you from day one that the only purpose
of the corporation is to enrich
shareholders
maybe one of the most destructive ideas
in uh humanity
that's right and and for
folks listening to the podcast what's
really important to remember
about that claim is that it wasn't
that milton friedman first made that
claim in 1972 and it got enshrined into
policy and culture and everything else
and certainly corporate behavior
but milton friedman was making a much
broader claim than it sounds
he didn't just say he wasn't effectively
say
saying screw working people you oh the
only thing you have to work at
worry about is enriching yourselves he
made a much broader claim which is
if you screw working people and
only worry about yourselves that will be
good for everyone
including working people that was the
big claim right
is that his claim was that by
maximizing value for shareholders the
entire society would benefit
including the workers who got screwed
and people bought it i mean it's hard to
believe
but they're very pervasive you know
that's what came out of harvard business
school then everyone was like well
like the harvard people are saying this
so yeah sounds good to me
will my bonus be better talk about your
engagement with policy because i'm
really curious myself really and like
because i think that you and i have a
lot in common so as you know i run an
enterprise called civic ventures
which is um sort of my
version my wife and my version
of philanthropy and instead of just
giving dough away to the united way or
you know the local hospital what we try
to do is create
structural change at the intersection of
policy and politics
and one of the anchor strategies or
assumptions that we make about social
change in america
is that all important big change
starts locally so so whether it was the
eight hour day
or marijuana legalization or given what
you know like
uh you know you pick the big policy
it started in a city or state is staff
established
the policy proved that it worked then it
went bigger and so what we do is look
for transformational opportunities
that can catalyze national action but
that we can
try um first in either our city or state
or another
so fun you're like the the uh civic
innovation lab and you look around and
say all right
we're gonna roll out a 15 an hour
minimum wage which you did in seattle
what year
uh that was uh 2013. in 2012
um my partner our partners at seiu
had uh um workers go on strike for 15
around the country and at the same time
we started a campaign to raise the
minimum wage to 15
an hour in a small town called seatac
just out of seattle
and so we r we sort of pioneered the
idea
ran the camp ran the initiative campaign
and won by like
60 votes or something like that in this
small town
but that effort completely transformed
the mayor's race that was happening at
the same time in seattle and so
the guy that was um got uh elected mayor
got elected on a platform of raising the
minimum wage to 15 in seattle
and he created a working group uh that i
was part of there were 20 people
um and my colleague david rolfe uh
co-chaired it
he he co-chaired it and uh and you know
and we pushed through 15
i don't know 90 days later or something
like that in seattle
yeah and then see it then it turned out
that
seattle did not slide into the ocean and
it did not rain cats and dogs and stuff
like that they actually did quite well
didn't they that's right
and then you know unemployment fell from
5.9 to 3.9 percent in the following two
years and
and and and then it went to san
francisco
and then you know around the country
which is
how social change happens david and i
cooked up this idea for 15
in response to the obama administration
calling for raising the minimum wage to
nine dollars an hour
from 7.25 and we were like if these are
our friends
who needs enemies right like i love it
you know like
if this is the best the president of the
united states can do
we need a new plan and so we
i mean just between us chickens well i
guess it's a podcast so everybody will
know
we never expected to win
we so the number 15
sounds like a lot to people but if
productivity if
the minimum wage had tracked
productivity gains oh yeah
22 or something like that that's crazy
if you look at those curves
that's right and so we knew that 15 was
a relatively conservative number on a
historical basis it's actually halfway
between
the inflation number and the
productivity number but it seems like a
very significant leap forward because
oh yeah all the time yeah but by rights
it should be 25
nationally today yeah and and to be
clear
andrew if it was we would live in a very
different country
very different wouldn't we we would live
in a very different country
both economically and politically
because a lot of the economic division
that we're
experiencing is a consequence of the
anger
that has been created by the
just objective truth of most people
getting screwed over the last 40 years
right and some people lean left and some
people leaning right but the
anger is totally valid and
we have to deal with it
[Music]
all right this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by the new yorker i don't
know if you guys watched the hbo
documentary on
allen v farrow it's fascinating but one
of their best journalists
at the new yorker is ronan farrow and
he's a genius the new yorker
is just one of the better places where
you can get real deep dives into
specific topics and stuff i i've always
been interested but haven't particularly
spent time on reading so i read two
articles i found fascinating i found one
about
american christianity and how it's
shaped frankly and gone to places that i
didn't think
christianity was going to and it's
really become very political in a weird
way
and then that was called the wasting of
an evangelical mind and the other one i
read was called emails making us
miserable which it is
um so this type of stuff you get from
the new yorker which is fascinating so
here's the deal for a limited time you
can get 12 weeks of the new yorker for
just six dollars that's a savings you
get 50
off it's awesome plus listeners of our
show will receive an exclusive tote bag
to carry around
for free so go to newyorker.com yang
that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r-dot-com
yang to get 12 weeks new yorker for six
bucks
and free tote bag newyorker.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
well i love the vision and one of the
reasons why
i love it is that it just values
people's time
at a more appropriate rate one of the
reasons why like i'm
pro-universal basic income relative to
other measures is that it values some of
the
time that right now doesn't get
considered as
employment and right um you know like
for example
you know my wife is at home with our
boys and you know like uh right that
doesn't count zero in gdp calculation
yeah zero zero
but but there is but the the same
principle uh applies where
if you were elevating people's wages
you're just valuing people's time more
like 100 percent
on pro ubi is like just you should just
value people's time
like intrinsically and right like so but
the principle
um is is very similar it's one reason
why when you talk about
um you know elevating these things like
i i just imagine more human dignity
which there
there is um immediately so so you
surprise yourself and win
um and then you're like oh my gosh like
we're getting this done in seattle and
then
that happens 90 days that's right and
seiu drove it super hard and super
successfully around the country
um yeah that's right mary kay henry did
an
extraordinary job in leadership there um
cj grimes who ran the national fight for
was amazing and a bunch of other people
who you know i could mention but
then the question to your point is
andrew what's next
right because the minimum wage is like
it's a start but there's a thousand
things that you can do
and i will tell you in my opinion what
the second most important thing is
that we have been fighting since 2014 i
think
is the overtime threshold speaking of
time
so the overtime threshold is the
threshold below which
if you if you work for more than 40
hours a week they have to pay you time
and a half
and in the day like when we used to have
a thriving middle class
40 years ago that threshold covered
not just 100 of hourly workers
but it also covered 62
of salaried workers which means that
effectively
it covered almost everybody except the
big bosses
okay and what happened over 45 years of
neoliberalism
is that that so a people like me
turned uh hourly workers
into salaried workers and pitch them
fake titles like assistant manager or
director of you're on your way filing
yes
and you get a business card and
then that standard fell um
to to uh and it just got updated but
as of last year if you earned 23
600 a year or less
you've got overtime but that means if
you were in twenty three thousand seven
hundred dollars federally
and i call you assistant manager i can
make you work seventy hours a week
and not pay you one more dollar than i
was keynes projected
that we'd have like a 15 hour work week
by now because we're so productive
um and then he got the productivity
number right but our work week has just
gotten longer and longer because of some
of the things they're describing
because i was like oh you're there and
like work is work just kind of expands
yes it does it does and because
people like me employing other people
had this enormous incentive to turn
three 40-hour a week jobs into two
60-hour week jobs
right is if i don't have any limit on
how hard i can press people to work
then what i want to do is is
get two people to work as much as three
used to and pocket the difference right
imagine how profitable that is
imagine how profitable that is to have a
thousand people working 40 hours a week
and then on presto magico now you have
650 people working 60 hours a week
for the same price i remember one of the
things that
that expanded the work week this is
gonna date me a little bit but whatever
um it was blackberries like as soon as
you had a blackberry then like then
people could get you any time and then
obviously that they've morphed into
smartphones and people can get it at
people any time and now no
for sure week goes on forever but but
one of the reasons the work week goes on
forever is that all those people with
blackberries
were not protected by this labor
standard
right because in the day you couldn't
get people to work at home they'd be
like well now you have to pay me
overtime
so is the plan to have the overtime
threshold uh
applied to salaried workers as well as
wage workers well
it is presently applied to salaried
workers
at 32 000 a year which applaud which
effectively is
almost no salaried workers um but again
using this theory of local first
change in washington state last year
we pushed through uh the nation's
highest
uh overtime threshold i believe i
believe it is
tell us more tell us more and at full
implementation it will be at about
eighty three thousand dollars
so what we are presently doing is
is putting pressure on the department of
labor and the biden administration
to in either enact a law or change the
labor standard
so that if you earn 83
000 a year or less you are automatically
entitled to overtime pay it time and a
half if you work
more than 40 hours a week this would be
transformative and i will say it would
be
a job creator in many many contexts
because someone would look up
and say wait a minute i'm going to have
to pay my workers overtime because right
now they're working
55 hours a week and that's time and a
half so how about i go employ
like another set of people to try and
keep everyone at 40.
that's right and so one of the secrets
to understanding
why wages have not risen for a really
long time
is that if you can 40 million
times across the economy turn three jobs
into two
well you've taken 15 million jobs out of
the economy plus or minus or 12 million
jobs or whatever it is
right and this is why structural
unemployment is so high
is because companies can get workers to
work more hours
without being forced to hire more people
and so everybody's just on this
treadmill
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help
i am doing better help i'm actually
doing it once a week
it's like 90 bucks a week not even
for basically as many sessions as you
want schedule and i talked to my
person let's call her sarah that's not
her real name but i won't i won't share
your real name but i talk to sarah all
the time i once a week and it's great
and we talk about a whole host of things
and you can do it too so you can talk
about depression
anxiety stress relationships sleeping
trauma family conflicts anger you name
it we kind of cover the gamut
so i really do encourage this
particularly in covid guys like
get this stuff out of your system it is
awesome so here's our call to action for
you i want you to start living happier
life today
and do what i'm doing and as a listener
you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people and
me too who have taken charge their
mental health that's betterhelp
help.com slash yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so when you say that you launched this
initiative in washington state what does
that process look like
on this particular uh policy change
we didn't have to pass an initiative we
simply had to persuade the labor
department
to change the standard so the state of
washington
in the state of washington so that took
a a
it took us about a year of strategizing
organizing and political pressure and
sort of narrative in the press but if we
like if you want the last time we raised
the minimum wage in the state of
washington we did via initiative among
other things
that my team does is we run all the gun
violence politics in the state we stood
up an
organization called the alliance for gun
responsibility and we have now
passed four statewide initiatives and
probably
25 laws uh to
make the state safer from gun violence
but to
pass an initiative you need to you need
to
write the law uh you need to get
the attorney general to um
uh essentially uh say it's okay and to
assign it a ballot title
and then you need to collect about 350
000 signatures and then you need to win
the campaign
uh and uh and you know i
i have you know civic ventures is a team
of
political professionals that are
absolutely world class at doing all of
those things
and so we write the law
you know collect the signatures run the
campaign
raise the money so awesome and then
and then do it again so you got a
version of this past in washington state
uh the where the overtime threshold
changed
um and what year was that last january
it went into effect but yeah oh yeah
yeah so
over time we put a full court press on
the obama administration to change the
overtime threshold
and to make an extraordinarily long
story short
um they came up short that they went
about half as far as they should have
and they did it at the very last minute
of the second term
and as soon as they were and they didn't
fully implement it and soon as soon as
the republicans came into power they
killed it the obama white house
issued a report on the automation of
labor and they literally issued it
like it was something like december like
uh
29th uh like 2000 like
16 or like whatever it was like last day
in office they sent out a report being
like
and you're screwed yeah the report was
very frightening the report was like and
we're going to automate away 83 percent
of jobs that like you know
where people get paid 20 bucks or less
at present and it was like
turn the lights out yeah
so that was like was one of my my
experiences where i was like well
it's like drop this bomb report like you
know on their way out of the office
um so so that that stinks that obviously
after trump takes off office they're not
gonna
adopt those changes it has not gone all
the way to 83 it takes
four years more i think you know it's
it's a phase-in thing
in washington state as it probably
should be everywhere just to get
give people a chance to um accommodate
it
but um uh but now
we're driving hard to try to get the
administration to adopt
that standard nationally wow
so so is is this a marty walsh thing or
is this a joe biden thing or who
comes on this one both i mean it's the
marty walsh i mean we're talking to
um the folks who work for marty walsh in
in the
labor department and um but we're
also circulating the idea of actually
passing
this legislatively between you and me
if i was biden i would want to try to
pass this legislatively because
just politically and economically there
is no policy that is available to
democrats
that more directly benefits
middle-class people do you know what i
mean like the minimum wage
is fantastic this would be a yeah no
this would be a big deal for a lot of
people
it would be a huge transformative deal
for tens of millions of americans
many of whom voted for donald trump in
the last election
right okay nick so yeah so what is the
catchy name for
uh for this measure
well it's overtime and i guess what
you're saying to me is
that's a really crappy not very catchy
name
so i which i'm admitting
because right now i'm like let's
champion overtime before people are like
all right
though i understand how incredibly
transformative it would be positively
wait wait wait i've got i've got i've
got i've got i've got it okay
all right fight for 40. fight for 40.
that's a good you know what that's
pretty goddamn good
that's not bad right because fight for
15 was very very
successful and alliterative and like you
hear it
so you say fight for 40. a star is born
i think it's pretty good it's pretty
good right because you're here and
you're like
like fight for 40 you're like 40 bucks
an hour it's like no 40 hours a week
and then you're like oh 40 hours a
week um and then it's like yeah and if
you're working for more than that then
you should get paid overtime and
everyone will be like hell yeah
fight for 40 nick i think that is
absolutely terrific
i i well more to come
on all the little buttons we're gonna
have a little asterisk and say
bye andre yang no no no no no no credit
necessary just freaking
um as long as it happens you know like
i'm
i'm i'll be very very glad and and you
know one of the most encouraging things
going is the biden administrations
and you know i think the democratic
party's acknowledgment
generally that this is a time for bold
action
yeah that's that's been what my
conversations with them have also
indicated like they need to deliver the
goods
they have a window of time where that
like government has to demonstrate that
it can actually
improve do yeah yeah yeah and so
you know the time is ripe for i think a
much more constructive dialogue about
this particular thing but anyway i mean
you know like there's a thousand little
things one of the things that
and i'm not sure how you feel about this
but one of my little bugaboos
is non-competes if you're earning 65 000
a year and hanging on by your
fingernails the last thing you're going
to do is go to war with a lawyer over
whether your non-compete is enforceable
and until
recently places like jimmy john's were
forcing
uh people who made sandwiches for seven
dollars an hour into
into signing non-competes too but
but the thing about non-competes is it's
just a way to
move power from individuals
to corporations so imagine a world in
which nobody ever
could had to sign a non-compete except
maybe the ceo
which meant that at any point you could
offer your services and skills
to the people across the street who are
competing well guess what happens to
wages
right they go up a lot for a lot of
people
for the vast majority of workers uh the
non-compete should not
be appropriate i i totally agree with
this um so keep going we've got those
three
because i i personally think the fight
for 40 is
something that we really should be um
driving hard because that would be
a game changer would create millions of
jobs like
around the country i'm thinking um or
would like see a lot more money going to
people's hands
100 it's so benign like most people
looking up would be like
sure like fighting 40 who's not going to
be for that yeah yeah yeah no
you're absolutely right and and it does
two things it it it
it creates millions of jobs but it also
increases
lots of you know millions and millions
and millions of people's wages
not just andrew because they all of a
sudden earn
overtime but even more because their
employers are like
look it is too complicated to track this
you make 70. i'm raising you at 83 just
so i don't have to deal with this you're
like a lot of people are
making 83. a lot of people in america
anybody between 65 and 83 would probably
all of a sudden be making 83.
and uh or 83 0001 or whatever and that's
to the good
right like that's an amazing you know
that's an amazing yeah i think the
threshold at which
people's happiness reaches like a you
know near optimal level
is like 75 000 so you're you're trying
to land at 83 actually makes a lot of
sense from a human perspective just
just say it just share it yeah but you
know as you know andrew there's so many
things that we have to do to get the
country back on track we have to find a
way to
properly tax the very wealthy and use
that money to make investments in
the in you know in the country we have
to pay people
fairly and we have to get our you know
we and we have to reform our democracy
and make sure that this
insane amount of uh voter suppression
that the
right to engaging in right now is you
know is headed off at the pass
it's just it's it's super embarrassing
well nick talking to you is very very
uplifting uh which i knew it would be i
was very excited for a reason
um if someone wants to follow you uh
support your work
uh hear your thoughts you have written a
couple of books
but your podcast is pitchfork economics
like how else can someone keep track of
you
and lend a hand to civic ventures or
anything you're doing
yeah well i mean civic ventures is you
know on the internet
my i'm you know i'm at nick hannah or on
twitter
uh if you're interested in a sometimes
profane
uh and uh i use the f word on his
podcast
let the fight for 40 commence if that
becomes a thing i'm going to be so
proud nick i'm not going to lie it's a
really good idea
uh i i i'm being serious uh as soon as i
hang up i'm going to run that by some
people i think it's incredibly clever
well nick so glad to connect let's keep
in touch all the best
uh in your quest to help
people and families and workers get more
of what they deserve in this economy
and uh hopefully we'll be able to
celebrate some victories sometime soon
i love it i love it well thank you for
having me andrew it's always so great to
[Music]
connect
you